cette agricultrice cherche à protéger sa
santé contre une menace invisible
dès que j'ai commencé à faire les
arrosages j'ai voulu porter une
combinaison parce que on nous a
tellement parlé des effets néfastes à
l'école des fois même quand j'arrose
avec mon tracteur avec la cabine
changerai mon coeur j'ai eu mal de
paille tu ailles dias nong aimerait
utiliser moins de pesticides pour lutter
contre les insectes et les mauvaises
herbes dans ses cultures de maïs et de
soya
mais elle se sent forcé de le faire les
inscrits peuvent toujours être plus
performant ça ressemble plus de ram
les chars les plus propres possibles sur
chaque hectare cultivé on épand
maintenant deux kilos de ces produits
chimiques par année un record selon le
gouvernement les quantités vendues ont
considérablement augmenté en l'espace de
six ans certains pesticides sont
surutilisés comme les néonicotinoïdes
aux effets destructeurs sur les colonies
d'abeilles il y à aussi l'atrazine
interdite depuis plus de 10 ans en
europe mais pas chez nous est celui qui
connaît la plus forte croissance
le glyphosate il vient d'être classé
cancérigène probable par l'organisation
mondiale de la santé
la majorité des producteurs sont pas
concernés des impacts des pesticides
dans leur santé pour mesurer la présence
de ces produits dans la nature le
ministère de l'environnement du québec a
prélevé des milliers d'échantillons dans
les rivières des régions agricoles
les analyses viennent tout juste d'être
publié les résultats démontrent une
présence de plus en plus forte des
pesticides dans l'eau dans la
quasi-totalité des échantillons
recueillis
on a retrouvé des produits considérés
par le gouvernement comme les plus
risqués pour l'environnement et la santé
dans la rivière st régis par exemple on
a retrouvé une concentration
d'insecticides qui dépassait de 73 fois
le critère de qualité de l'eau un autre
produit le chlorpyrifos dépassé même la
concentration acceptable pour maintenir
la vie aquatique
pourtant depuis quatre ans québec s'est
donné comme objectif de réduire de 25 %
l'impact des pesticides mais c'est tout
le contraire qui est en train de se
passer
ces résultats cause un malaise au
gouvernement le ministère de
l'environnement nous a dit ne pas
vouloir aborder ce sujet pour le moment
quant au bureau du ministre de
l'agriculture pierre paradis
il a aussi décliné nos demandes il nous
a fallu le surprendre dans un corridor
oui on doit s'inquiéter parce que le
rapport actuel est négatif et tant que
la tendance ne sera pas inversé on doit
s'inquiéter d'un essai d'utilisation de
mondialiste cette année on ferme ans
avec une infestation de mauvaises herbes
qui s'appelle la morelle noire
sylvain gascon a tenté d'utiliser moins
de produits chimiques mais sa récolte
est un échec et il ne peut plus la
commercialiser à confins erreur car
qu'on n'est pas accompagnée pour face et
le suivi de jeu les fêtes cette année le
gouvernement à couper dans les services
d'agronomes pour aider les producteurs
québec a aussi considérablement réduit
ses subventions dans la recherche et le
développement d'alternatives plus
écologique d investissement de 11
millions et demi en 2013
on est passé à un peu plus d'un million
cette année faire des compressions et
accompagner - les producteurs faire
moins de recherche à voir -
d'inspecteurs c'est sûrement pour
compatir avec l'objectif de réduire de
25 %
les usages de pesticides et des hommes
c'est pendant que les agriculteurs sont
livrés à eux mêmes c'est l'industrie des
pesticides qui prend le relais de l'état
et combler le vide quand j'ai pas accès
à ma conseillère mon à grenoble mais
c'est l'agronome de la compagnie qui me
va mais mais ce type avec une solution
c'est eux qui te vendent un produit mais
c'est aussi qu'ils te conseille dans ta
gestion des pesticides donc c'est comme
une espèce de relation étroite question
qui est un peu malsaine
les experts dans le milieu pour un usage
des hommes ciel des pesticides sont
principalement les fabricants et les
distributeurs de ces produits se
représente en un collectif de compagnies
comme monsanto syngenta défend les
conseillers de l'industrie essayer
d'améliorer le rendement des producteurs
et c'est ça leur but principal était un
protégeant l'environnement et la santé
humaine
le sujet fait débat jusque dans les
familles d'agriculteurs maintenant c'est
moi qui fais les arrosages qu'à chaque
fois que ouais mais tu es content a
débarrassé cheaibi le père et le fils
sont parvenus à se débarrasser des
pesticides mais au prix d'importants
efforts plus de suivi plus de labour
plus de temps dans les champs la mère et
la fille elle n'arrive pas encore à se
passer de l'aide chimiques
oui la civic a fait confiance parce que
moi j'ai toujours dans mon idée je veux
éviter la contamination des mauvaises
herbes qu'on perd le contrôle jusqu'à
pas de comprendre que les agriculteurs
qui font beaucoup d'heures ont besoin
d'avoir une qualité de vie qui n'ont pas
le goût de passer leur vie dans le champ
la prochaine génération d'agriculteurs
arrivera-t-elle à se passer de ces
produits toxiques qui facilite leur
travail
le gouvernement se donnera t-il les
moyens nécessaires pour réduire leur
présence
le gouvernement vise à une réduction de
ses produits c'est tout le contraire de
vue le ministre mal à l'aise dans le
reportage
thomas l'autre question les impacts sur
la santé sur notre santé oui et pas
facile d'y répondre simplement santé
canada qui homologue ces produits nous
dit que monsieur madame tout le monde
non pas une exposition suffisante pour
avoir de l'inquiétude de toute façon
notre eau potable est testé en revanche
les puits les agriculteurs et de leurs
voisins eux on a détecté déjà de faibles
doses et même de faibles doses de ces
pesticides ça peut avoir un impact
comme le mentionne le toxicologue de la
santé publique l'exposition à de très
faibles doses de certains produits pour
avoir des conséquences sur la santé
humaine
on parle par exemple de produits qui ont
des effets sur ce thème endocriniens
alors dans le reportage on parlait
notamment du produit glyphosate qui a
été reconnu comme cancérigène probable
par l'organisation mondiale de la santé
on a appris que québec en ce moment est
en train d'étudier ce qu'elle va
reconnaître cet état de fait la cette
recherche là et à ce moment là il y
aurait des conséquences est ce qu'on
arrêterait d'utiliser ce qu'on le
limiterait y aurait des conséquences
économiques
et on attend le plan de québec encore
une fois merci à thomas au revoir